la ira sigue creciendo por tercera noche
consecutiva en chino zou wisconsin
después de que el afroamericano jake
blake recibiera siete disparos por la
espalda por parte de un policía el
pasado 23 de agosto en los disturbios de
anoche tres personas recibieron disparos
dos de ellas murieron los hechos se
produjeron horas después de que el
gobernador declarara el estado de
emergencia y prometiera desplegar tropas
adicionales de la guardia nacional en un
intento por restablecer el orden de la
ciudad
le dispararon a mi hijo siete veces
siete veces como si no importara pero mi
hijo importa si jake o supiera lo que
está pasando en cuanto a la violencia ya
la destrucción estaría muy disgustado
por su parte la policía dice haber
respondido a lo que describió como un
incidente doméstico el domingo que
argumentan que checo blake incumplió las
órdenes de la policía
el abogado de blake dice que será un
milagro si vuelve a caminar y harper
con una bala atravesó parte o toda su
médula espinal al menos una bala
tiene agujeros en el estómago le
tuvieron que extirpar casi todo el colon
y el intestino delgado sufrió daños en
su riñón e hígado y también le
dispararon en el brazo y software de
e-mail
sídney en 9
a 70 días de las elecciones con la
convención nacional republicana en pleno
apogeo el presidente camps ha pedido al
gobernador demócrata de wisconsin que
llame a más efectivos de la guardia
nacional mientras tanto el candidato
demócrata joe biden ha condenado el
tiroteo de la policía y pide una
investigación completa y transparente